[Musique]
cette première visite d'une délégation
canadienne à Taïwan depuis le début de
la pandémie a commencé en écoutant les
discours nationalistes des politiciens
locaux aussi vibrations de la fête
nationale de Taïwan lundi
parlementaires canadiens de meurent
prudents dans leur commentaire sur la
menace d'invasion chinoise alors moi
personnellement
il faut quand on vient c'est pas pareil
que tout ce qu'on entend
les députés ont visité les institutions
démocratiques taïwanaises et mis
l'accent sur les occasions d'affaires
comme tant d'autres pays le Canada veut
assurer ses approvisionnements en
semi-conducteur Taïwan produit 90% des
micro puces les plus avancés du monde
où les États-Unis l'Europe et la Chine
veulent augmenter leur propre production
de semi-conducteurs le Canada aimerait
aussi devenir un fabricant
ce voyage la délégation canadienne va
aider à élaborer la stratégie canadienne
Indo-Pacifique qui doit toujours être
publiée d'ici la fin de l'année c'est le
souhait exprimé par la ministre des
Affaires étrangères Mélanie Joly
cette stratégie vise à diversifier les
liens économiques du Canada dans la
région mais aussi à contrer l'influence
de la Chine avec le troisième mandat
historique devrait obtenir le Président
si gingping en fait semaine la Chine
n'entend poursuivre et même accéléré sa
montée en puissance et en influence en
hindou Pacifique il suffit Leblanc
Radio-Canada